宇宙之前
所谓“之前”，我们还不知道。
时间的边界
时间是否有起点，仍是未知。
抵达理论边界
现有理论无法描述最初一刻。
空间急剧拉伸
暴涨假说：微小起伏被放大。
热大爆炸
宇宙进入炽热、致密的早期。
粒子的海洋
膨胀与冷却，改变物质形态。
物质开始成形
夸克结合，质子与中子形成。
最初的元素核
最初几分钟，轻元素核诞生。
宇宙变得透明
电子被俘获，原子开始形成。
最古老的光
这束余辉，今天仍能被看见。
宇宙的黑暗时代
恒星尚未点燃，引力悄然工作。
第一批恒星
气体聚拢，终于点燃核聚变。
星光亮起
第一代恒星，照亮漫长黑夜。
光改变了宇宙
星光逐渐让星系间气体再电离。
引力编织宇宙网
物质沿丝状结构汇聚，星系生长。
亿万星辰成河
恒星与气体，汇成壮丽星系。
恒星锻造元素
恒星演化与爆发，丰富了元素。
我们来自星尘
碳、氧、铁，成为新世界的原料。
太阳系诞生
尘埃在年轻太阳周围聚集。
一颗蓝色星球
尘埃聚成地球，海洋逐渐出现。
生命展开
地球上，生命演化出复杂世界。
宇宙开始被追问
直到今天，我们开始追问来处。
走到此刻
宇宙约138亿岁，仍在膨胀。
远方渐不可及
若加速膨胀继续，远方渐不可及。
太阳也会老去
约50亿年后，太阳走向红巨星。
最后的星光
漫长岁月后，恒星时代渐近尾声。
残骸的漫长时代
若持续冷却，残骸将主宰长夜。
黑洞也非永恒
理论预言：黑洞也会缓慢蒸发。
差异逐渐消散
可用于做功的能量梯度持续衰减。
从未知，到寂静
热寂或是终章，但并非定论。